everyone can call themselves an
entrepreneur but to me an entrepreneur
somebody that at one point was an
independent contractor who graduated the
mindset of winking their way to the top
because that's just not possible you see
you can read a lot about entrepreneurs
you can watch Shark Tank you can watch
Gary Vee you can watch all these guys
you can read about Peter Drucker you can
read about all these Steve Jobs you can
read so much about it but the reality of
it is 99% of what these guys did are
things no one ever sees because it's
done behind closed doors no one sees
about it you hear about it there are
rumors about it you may read about it in
an article you may hear about it in a
store you may have Guy Kawasaki talk
about how it was when he was at Apple or
Steve Wozniak talk about how was to work
with Steve Jobs but the reality of it is
99% no one sees and unfortunately the
same goes with the entrepreneurs who are
buried in the cemetery of entrepreneurs
who didn't make it because no one sees
what they do 99% of the time behind
closed doors see I know this I relate to
this because I would try to win my way
to the top and it didn't work and have
to eventually realize if I want to
really be known as an entrepreneur if I
want to really be known as a CEO it's
other people calling you a CEO or an
entrepreneur now you can call yourself
whatever you want you can call yourself
anything you want to call yourself now
that you just got to catch a camera get
on camera say I am a startup serial
entrepreneur investor about that all
this stuff you can put for yourself but
it doesn't necessarily make it true so
today I'm going to talk about ten signs
that you're wing in your business so
let's start off with number one to me
when you think about business to me when
you think about the word business like
if you think about the word love what
does love mean to you I got to ask
myself is going to love to me as an
action love to me is not a feeling love
to me is an action you take action to
show love to somebody right what is the
word business mean to your mind when you
think about the word business or
entrepreneur what do you think about to
me it's all numbers it's all numbers
business is all numbers entrepreneurship
is all numbers so number one sign that
your ring in your business is not
tracking your business so what every
time I'm not tracking your business what
can I track everything in your
business can be tracked every single
thing in your business can be tracked
when I go and look at the different
departments that we grew any departments
that we grew we grew our licensing out
by one hundred and ten percent okay I
had to go back and look at areas myself
that we were not tracking once we did
that and we started tracking a license I
went to the roof okay I have to go back
and look at other business and sales
volumes or promotions or whatever it is
and it grows but I need data you need
data if I go back and look at me as a
new entrepreneur getting started as a
new independent contractor trying to
become an entrepreneur running my own
office staff team executives etc etc I
have to look at what can I measure I can
measure how many calls I made in a day
and every single day I can measure out
on my course how many people pick up at
what time do they pick up do I leave
messages when is a good time to call
people in their home when is a good time
to get a hold of them is it good to
leave a message if I leave a message
what kind of message do I leave if I go
on ten appointments how many times do I
close if I close five out of ten what do
I close what's my mixture of products I
sell do I just sell this for instance if
I'm selling this if I'm running a subway
I have let's just say ten different
options I'm going to look at which one
do we sell the most why do we sell that
the most why don't we sell this more why
don't we sell doublemeat more who's
offering doublemeat would you like to
make that a double meet are we selling
the combos are we asking for the combos
are we selling the cookies are we asking
for the cookies how many cookies do we
sell out of 100 sales how many cookies
do we sell why's it at this store out of
a hundred sales in a day they sell 28
cookies this store out of 100 sales in a
day they sell six cookies I want to go
find out what these guys are doing this
is all measuring this is all measuring
and the more I measure the more I can go
and ask and say why is it that you guys
sell 28 cookies to 100 customers and a
person will say we always offer the
cookies we always ask for cookies so one
cookie is a buck 29-28 cookies times 10
sales is now times 100 sales not really
that many Cooke dollars it's maybe 35
bucks 40 bucks that I'm getting
additional data but times 30
that's 1,200 dollars that this subway is
bringing in that this always not
bringing it so I need to know these
types of numbers don't forget if it's
subway if it's real estate if it's
insurance if it's financial services it
doesn't matter in every possible way I
can find a measure
figure to track so I can drive it if I
don't know numbers there's nothing I can
do about it so for instance if somebody
says I think we're around we're about I
believe we're doing this
I think we're doing this you're still
winging it because you need to know your
numbers and the more your numbers you
know quarter-to-quarter monthly the
monthly I want to be prior quarters all
the time I want to be prior best what's
the most we've ever done in a month and
XYZ I want to beat that what's the most
we've ever done in in this court in X I
want to beat that what's the best summer
we've ever had what's the best sprint I
want to beat those numbers because
that's what entrepreneurs who become
CEOs do but independent contractors they
don't do second thing that you're
weighing in your business you're not
running your business based on systems
see a lot of times you'll meet people
and you may say well you know a lot of
entrepreneurs have personalities that's
actually not true not all entrepreneurs
have big personalities because you can't
built your business on a big personality
it's mathematically impossible to build
your business on a personality
it only has a limit on how much you can
grow you can say well I'm going to build
my business because I know my products
better than anybody else that so it's
product knowledge that's also limited
amount because there's always going to
be somebody that knows more about
products than you but systems allows you
to draw your business systems systems
and systems used to be the most boring
thing either the Facebook mentions
yesterday and I said it's unfortunate
because you know most people who watch
Facebook mentions or watch videos like
this they don't like to hear boring
stuff it's always motivational that kind
of motivates me a lot Pat I love when
you do motivational stuff I love when
you do this we got one of the most
sincere comments the other day from
YouTube one of my closest fans who
watches every single episodes and
comments all the time
he says Patrick please never become a
motivational speaker I watch your videos
because I'm truly getting content
instead of theories and all this other
stuff that some other people say that
they charge $10,000 keep talking about
the stuff that's business not running a
system is going to cost how big of a
business you can build and when people
tell me things like this when they say
things like this you know I tried
running a business but the business owns
you you ever hear that thing tell you
when you run a business you don't really
own the business the business owns you
because I know
if you chose to build it that way that's
not how professionals do it
you chose to build it that way and you
state an independent contractor when you
build a real business you own the
business because you run it based on
systems if you don't have systems the
business owns you because it's driven
based on your personality and product
knowledge that's a limited business to
scale you're going to have a based on
systems in every part of your business
you can look and say what can I create a
system for this what can I create a
system for this number three not a
predictable schedule if you you know I
hear people say well you know I became a
business owner because I don't want to
have a boss so if I want to come in at
11 o'clock I'm going to come in at 11
o'clock well you can find your way back
to a job very quickly if you keep coming
in at 11 o'clock you can do that but
you'll be back at a job coming on at 8
o'clock then you're forced to do that or
else you'll have a write-up yeah you've
got to have a predictable schedule you
gotta have a time you come in you get
out of time that you leave you gotta
have a time that you show up you're
gonna have a time that you're doing
things there's got to be a lot of
predictability to your schedule if
Quiznos is late one minute people
complain if sub weighs late opening five
minutes corporates going to complain
when I worked at Bally's they told us
you got to open up at four o'clock or
five o'clock you have to open up that
time if you don't open up that time
people are waiting outside of going to
the gym that's complained to the Home
Office and you're getting fired if you
don't open up the gym if somebody didn't
open up the gym on time you're fired
if someone didn't close the gym on time
and you kept it the open it close it
earlier you're fired because you got to
let people work out from midnight it
didn't matter what it is so you got to
have the same thing but if you want to
be independent on contract you can do
whatever you want to do but you're not
an entrepreneur you're not a business
owner yet you're still winging your
business if you don't have a pretty
predictable schedule if you know what
shows are playing on television in the
morning
you definitely are not an entrepreneur
yet now point number four you're cheap
you're too cheap
now I understand being a frugal I
totally understand but let me explain
what I mean by being cheap when you're
too cheap with your business when you're
too cheap with your business and you're
not willing to invest into getting the
supporting cast and assistant a good CPA
a good attorney and I'm not talking
you're going to do I do my own taxes I'm
not impressed by that you know I do my
own legal stuff because I write the
letters I'm good at writing
I worked at an attorney one time I'm not
impressed by that I do my own things
here okay that's great well then that
that's a $10 an hour job that's a 15
well I want to be I want to do this
you've got to be able to invest into
your business if you need an office you
got to get an office if you need to get
a you know executive suite open up your
business what you got to do it if you
need to get technology got to do it if
you need to there needs to be an
investment to your business you cannot
be cheap about it right and to your
business number five you're not willing
to make protocols for everything what is
protocols me for everything
let me explain to what I mean by
protocols for everything for instance
when we do this step number one is this
step number two is this Dennis this then
it's this then is this there's five
steps to Papapa there are 7 steps to dot
there's nine steps to Tata there's six
keys to hiring this there's five steps
to doing this there's got to be
protocols here's how we do this here's
how we do that the more you create that
everybody has an expectation because
everyone's now following that same
protocol so I may call it a system a
system maybe you know that you'll have
certain things that they do for certain
areas but this is more key steps that
you put together on what to do next
they're slightly similar but they're
also slightly different number six no
deadlines if you don't have deadlines
you're not an entrepreneur independent
contractor if you don't have a deadline
to finish the month strong then what are
your business for all because I don't
want people to tell me what to do well
really well what do you think these
people who go public after did have
quarterly calls what do you think when
you have an investor happens you don't
think they call and ask you questions
about what you're doing what do you
think happens if you really want to play
at the higher levels if you really want
to be this bigshot entrepreneur you know
CEO type it's purely accountability it's
purely responsibility and it's purely
around deadlines what are we going to
hit this when we're going to hit this
number what are we going to have by
today at five o'clock when you're going
to get this to me what are we going to
be able to pull this up when are we
going to hit this number here it's a lot
of deadlines if you don't have deadlines
you're purely winging it seven rarely
hitting goals you know it's very
exciting what what do you what anything
to do this month I think we're going to
do this this month and you don't hit it
next month I think we're going to do
this this month and you don't hit it
again I think we're going to do this
this money you don't hit it again you're
not really an entrepreneur yet
you are still an independent contractor
because you're not hitting goals you're
still missing goals so why are you
missing goals because you still don't
think you can't be that off your
projections that's not a professional
that's what an amateur does I understand
if you miss a 20% at a time maybe 30% of
the time we can be missing get 90% at a
time 80% at a time you're still an
amateur you still wing in your business
you're still wishful thinking you're
still hoping everybody else is going to
do something not you that's wishful
thinking right so rarely hitting goals
you got to have numbers you got to hit
it by the way sometimes this is a sign
of you putting way too big goals but
majority time believe it or not it's the
sign of you're not urgent to go out and
hit the numbers so there's not an
urgency for you to hit the numbers it
has nothing to with the size of the
goals it's rarely it's often not having
the urgency to want to go hit the
numbers number eight you react
instead of initiate meaning you lack
agency that may explain what I mean by
this it's a lot of reaction you react to
the marketplace you to react to somebody
quitting you react to a customer being
unhappy you react to you know it's
constant reacting than initiating hey
how do our customers feel let's do a
survey how do our agents feel how do you
feel about this what do you think about
this let's initiate hey I notice you
going through this is everything okay I
noticed this hey what's going on with us
you initiate your initiating hey calling
the customers I was just thinking about
you hey calling your initiating your
initiating context you're initiating
partnerships you're initiating
relationships instead of reacting okay
number nine not knowing what you want I
mean this is probably one of the most
common things of somebody I mean I'll
mentor somebody and I'll sit down I'll
say so what do you want and they'll say
this is what I want and a month later
it's the same and a quarter later it's
the same six months it's your latest
ascent you wonder why they're so focused
and they're growing because they know
what they want and they're clear about
it then it will talk to somebody asking
what they want one day they want this
and they were gung-ho about it month
later they still do but a month later
seasons change now they don't want it
anymore so you don't know how to talk to
them now three months and they don't
want that anymore you don't know what
had six months in it they don't so then
you don't know what you're really
wanting yourself you got to be very very
clear on what you want yourself if you
don't you
winging it there's got to be a solid -
time of solitude for you to write down
and say these are the reasons while I'm
doing this number ten number ten is no
desire to want to learn if you're not
learning you have no desire to want to
learn your wing in your business and
I'll tell you what I mean by no these
are the want to learn I'm not just
talking about reading self-help
motivational books I'm not just talking
about that I'm talking about studying
your business studying your craft
because to me when somebody doesn't want
to learn I take it as three different
things my interpretation of somebody not
reading or wanting to study their craft
and they're still winging it is one of
three things one they're simply lazy and
that's very often 80% of them that's why
most don't make it as entrepreneurs to
the highest level second is they think
they have all the answers and third is
they think very small so one you're lazy
- you think you have all the answers
three you think very small because if
you think very small you don't really
need to learn a lot more for you to be
able to scale yourself now watch this I
want you to understand this guy's
everything I say here today
it's from pure experience nothing I said
today it's things that I haven't
personally done nothing is every single
thing I told you today's areas of my
business career that I was frustrated
with that I had to eventually learn to
graduate because I would have been a
winging entrepreneur the rest of my life
and I would have been an independent
contractor calling myself an
entrepreneur calling myself a CEO but in
reality I'm just an independent
contractor that doesn't track anything
that has no deadlines that never hits my
goals that is too cheap that is not
willing to learn my business that I'm -
I'm just a regular guy that's trying to
wink in and I'll tell you one thing if
you go back if you go back and we'll put
a PDF you can go to the website to get
the PDF to kind of rank yourself and to
see which one of these things you do
very well one through ten you want to
make sure you get this in your hands be
sure to click on a link on the bottom to
go to Patrick video vidcom here's where
the website is Patrick made a vidcom go
to the website subscribe the newsletter
subscribe to the newsletter under the
link get the PDF look through it rate
yourself watch the video again and then
start improving those areas and I
promise you within a 90-day period
that's how quickly this will happen
within the 90-day
period night and day everyone who's
working with you will recognize a
different human being everyone said what
happened to you I don't recognize you
you know what happened to those days I
made a decision to no longer wing my
business mark my words you do this 90
days later you're going to see results
and in a year later major results two
years later you'll be shell-shocked on
where you're out with your business if
you go and take inventory of these ten
areas that most people win their
business and eventually you'll have
people calling you an entrepreneur and a
CEO if you haven't subscribed to this
channel please do so thanks for watching
take everybody